oh boy do I have a surprise for you guys
today and it's something I'm sure not
many of you have expected I think the
full bring Arc of bleach is the best Arc
I've read in this series and that
genuinely surprised me because going
into this bleach series it wasn't long
before I heard Whispers of a certain Arc
an arc that was held in either medium or
low regard amidst the vast majority of
its own Community I've only seen a few
praise it with others saying it was it's
okay all the while I've seen many call
it a very questionable creative Choice
needless to say there seems to be a
tremendous amount of division concerning
this Arc and I hope to put an end to
that today okay well maybe not in what
I've just realized isn't even so much
review as it is an analysis or Love
Letter to what has become easily my
favorite Arc in this series I'm toli
natsukushima and this is my love letter
to kubo's incredible full bring Arc
now I can already hear the tapping of
confused and angry fingers on keyboards
please save your energy and do not fret
it's possible you had an entirely
different experience with the material
to me and right now it's my job to
explain exactly why I think this Arc is
not only worthy of your time and
reconsideration but also most
importantly why I think it's better than
every other Arc that I've come across in
this series including the soul Society
now I like this Arc so much I read it
twice yeah okay okay yeah twice so how
is this possible I'm a reasonable person
I spend a lot of time reviewing manga
how did I Come Away with this point of
view well put quite simply this Arc does
everything I loved about the other arcs
really well while not being dragged down
by the criticisms I had for those very
arcs specifically in other words I think
this Arc enjoys all of the upsides with
very few if any of the downsides from
the prior arcs last time we touched base
with Ichigo we noticed he had lost his
powers and in a somewhat somber and
nostalgic fashion parted ways with Rukia
with her having now left both his View
and his perceptions seemingly forever
this was a surprisingly Bittersweet and
oddly fitting way to conclude not just
this Arc but perhaps the whole series I
thought making it one of the better
moments in the entire aranca Arc for me
which made me all the more curious as to
how the fulbring arc would make use of
this very unique situation
oh
one of the arguments I've heard as to
why this Arc isn't as enjoyable is due
to how it feels so much more
insignificant in scope and scale
compared to past outings and how in
essence it feels very much like a reset
now I don't think I can argue against
either of these points entirely though
what I would personally argue is that
these so-called negatives icy is actual
positives furthermore I'd say calling
this Arc a reset isn't entirely fair or
accurate either in fact I'd probably
argue that fullbring has the most
interesting continuation from one end of
an arc to the beginning of a new one
following the events that colored the
climax of The aranca Arc instead of
picking up immediately following that
very climax we instead are forced to
contend with a host of new and
refreshing problems for Ichigo to deal
with problems I would argue offer a look
into his character the other arcs either
didn't hit as sharply or didn't contend
with at all following the events of the
very first Arc substitute Shinigami and
the second Arc Soul Society ichigo's
path is Crystal clear whether the road
ahead may or may not be difficult Ichigo
has a clear goal to shoot for with the
correct stressors in place to give him
the convictions necessary to achieve his
goals rescue Rukia rescue Orihime this
act however is importantly different
instead of possessing a goal immediately
following the aranca arc Ichigo actually
makes a commendable sacrifice with the
story ending on a unique note one of
sacrifice and parting ways with a dear
friend seemingly for good and 17 months
passed by and he doesn't have a goal any
longer his life has returned to normal
in fact more normal than it otherwise
has ever been now that he's no longer
pastored by his one-time emerging power
set for the very first time in his life
he's a normal person whose only
expectation now is to take care of the
normal commitments that one would have
as a 17 year old boy growing up in Japan
those commitments being keeping up with
his friends striving to do well in
school diligently attend his
extracurricular activities and of course
his new part-time job however the Ichigo
we once knew isn't exactly there where
many series opt to use the time skip in
their stories to highlight the
progression of time and the evolution or
growth of a given character Allah Dragon
Ball one piece in Naruto Kubo decided to
use this time skip to highlight the lack
of growth or de-evolution of Ichigo
Kurosaki in belicha's fulbring Arc as
his grade slip he feels more distant
with his friends and loses interest in
out of school activities and commitments
where everyone else seems to be doing
well and preparing for the next stages
of their lives Ichigo seems to have his
mind squarely on what was now a
protector with no means of protecting
anyone requiring at times for those he
cares about to now pick up the slack
that he no longer can carry with this
very inability to let go of the past
leading to these strange dreams where he
hears Rookie's voice it's a very
compelling and sad way to kick this Arc
off particularly after a Time Skip and
following an arc with a length greater
than the Saiyan Frieza and cell sagas
combined with a a bloated and crippling
dedication to showing every fight no
matter how important it may or may not
be to the story having recycled a
motivation from a previous Arc for the
full bring Arc to Chronicle a story less
than one quarter the length all the
while focusing on ichigo's internal
struggle and the mistakes that stemmed
from that I found that very creative
choice and execution utterly fascinating
with it providing an introduction that
offered plenty in the way of possibility
without any of the cliche that plagued
Seoul society and eventually the Iraq
Iraq and that's not even to draw
attention to how they brilliantly
developed this story Into the second and
third acts for it's through this Despair
and sense of longing for what was that
leads Ichigo down the path which
ultimately defines this Arc
is an interesting character throughout
this Arc from beginning to end and he
achieves this by being a character that
constantly evolves in ways that
consistently add interest to the various
parts of the story that he participates
within making him in my estimation the
real MVP of this Arc with his second
interaction within the First Act of this
story between himself and Ichigo acting
as effectively his very own call to
action for Ichigo Ichigo thinks he knows
who urahara is he thinks he knows his
family well think again and perhaps most
importantly he offers Ichigo the chance
to get back everything he's longed for
these past 17 months his powers
following this interaction and segwaying
into the second act of the story this is
where fulbring once again I think does
something better than the other sections
of the story have were the iran-karak
and the Soul Society are devolved for a
time into a little too much fighting and
in the case of the former way too much
fighting the full bring Arc instead has
training with a heavy emphasis on
character interaction one of the
greatest strengths of the full bring Arc
I think is that it makes use of the fact
other arcs have already introduced a ton
of characters by only feeling the need
to introduce a few new ones in this
runtime and due to the main cast of this
Arc being centered around just a few
characters already familiar to us
through each ago we get to explore how
each of these characters grindo's allies
and friends all behave and treat each
other facilitating not only this segment
of the story but also achieving the
necessary build up for these
personalities when they ultimately
become used in the significantly more
action-focused conclusion and okay
that's another thing this Arc while the
first 75 has some fighting it's by no
means the focus and honestly that's the
ark's strongest aspect it's almost as if
Kubo said to himself you know what I
went a little overboard with the
fighting in the Iraq Iraq it's time to
write an emotional character-driven
mystery thriller and boy does he achieve
just that it's my favorite aspect of
this story and I'll definitely be
talking about it in just a moment but
before I do let's discuss the the core
focus of the arc and what is effectively
the mechanical driving force and
namesake of the arc itself let's discuss
the full bring mechanic
the full bring mechanic is one which has
been alluded to in Chad's ability prior
and while not being the focus of the arc
itself despite its namesake it is an
integral part of the arc itself without
which none of this would be possible and
thank God it is possible because the
ability is unpredictable and amorphous
nature in how it manifests in its users
is exactly what allows this Arc the
flexibility and freedom to deliver the
most memorable moments I've experienced
from this series the second act of the
story starts off with an obvious call to
action as I mentioned from ginjo however
it's initially when Ichigo doesn't trust
or is uncertain as to whether or not he
should explore that is until the
secondary plot and arguably the most
interesting narrative aspect of this
story is introduced as uru is pursuing
someone suspicious
foreign
[Music]
's father informs oruhime that Urdu
wasn't attacked by either a hollow or a
soul Reaper with his hypothesis being
that the next Target might be someone
similar to Urdu perhaps Chad or herself
or the Hime reminded once again of what
he needs to protect Ichigo throws
caution to the wind and makes contact
with ginjo and this is where he learns
how to use his full bring power and it's
where that clip of him with that
questionably large emblem comes from
also this section of the arc is
essentially about Ichigo trying to
regain the agency he's since lost both
literally and narratively the training
itself takes him to interesting
situations from being shrunk down into a
dollhouse fighting a yakuza's soul in
the body of a stuffed animal all the way
to fighting ginjou himself inside a
video game okay wow you're throwing a
lot at me here with Ichigo coming to
learn that the very Deputy badge he's
been carrying around is the key to his
full-bring ability and by extension the
restoration of his abilities symbolizing
a time where he had friendships he's
missed and Powers he could use to
protect them with however curiously once
again following his training he hears
arukia's voice following it forcing us
to contend with the possibility that
that dream where he thought he could
hear her was in fact linked to his badge
in some way
the best part
okay okay it was time to talk about the
best part of this Arc and by far the
part that gave me the most joy as I
mentioned there are a lot of ideas that
compound to make this Arc feel special
however around 60 to 75 of the way
through the arc itself following the
training reprieve the story itself does
something amazing by shifting and
transforming from what we've come to
know and expect from bleach into this
horrific psychological Thriller type
narrative seriously it's unlike anything
I've seen from this series and maybe
also unlike anything I've seen or come
across in both one piece Naruto Dragon
Ball or whatever it's such a unique idea
and it's explored in such a captivating
fashion I've always said that bleach
first and foremost has felt like a very
character-driven story with it producing
less interesting material when it takes
the focus off of the characters
themselves and so with full brings
introduction of this tonal shift it
takes what otherwise felt like a
refreshing Slice of Life reprieved from
the world ending Stakes of the prior Arc
into a set of circumstances that
genuinely felt more high stakes than
when ice reason was front and center for
me and that's not because I don't know
the difference in scale between the
world at stake and ichigo's life being
at stake but because each go is our
means of seeing through into this world
it's like our very existence in this
plane that we've now invested almost 500
chapters into is being stolen from us as
readers right before our eyes like [ __ ]
you tsukushima you didn't save Rukia you
didn't save Orihime or defeat Eisen we I
mean Ichigo did and while I think ginjo
is the MVP of this Arc I think
tsukishima is the other half of that
coin which grants this arcade level of
dread and excitement that for me has
been unmatched in this series one by one
we see him pick off ichigo's comrades
with his brush with Orihime being
particularly curious as this is where we
first start to get a taste of what his
power truly is with her not only
appearing perfectly fine physically
after what appeared to be a stabbing
through her heart but that she also
suddenly thought of him tsukushima as a
friend and as a Time takes on by and
conflicts fly past slowly but surely one
after another ichigo's former allies
suddenly appear to change not physically
but psychologically with the very fact
that these words are coming from his
friends making it all the more
unsettling showing up in his home his
place of work and on the street
tsukushima is less of an imposing force
of Nature and more so a ghostly specter
or spirit that follows Ichigo until he's
exhausted every support system he
possesses creating a scenario of not
just dread not just fear but one of
genuine confusion and hopelessness for
we much like Ichigo in this instance
have no clue as to the parameters of
this power tsukushima possesses he's
brainwashed everyone into thinking that
Ichigo is in the wrong here we have no
idea if Killian will result in the
desired outcome we want or if killingham
Will seal his friend's face as they
currently are brainwashed into believing
that tsukushima is their best friend and
almost like family and furthermore the
circumstances only push Ichigo and by
extension us into the arms of ginjou who
is at this point in the story the only
one left who can possibly help us making
that acceptance all the easier for us as
readers and that's important narratively
it's this fascinating philosophical and
emotional situation that made for a
climax that hand on my heart was more
exciting and had me on the edge of my
seat from the beginning to end then
practically no not practically every
other Arc in this series there were so
many twists turns and hopeful moments in
the final section that I can safely say
that I have never been more invested by
a storyline in Bleach however I will
caveat what I'm saying for just a moment
here for many of you out there that do
not share my opinion I cannot of course
speak to your experience perhaps if I
had been reading this week to week I
might be singing a different tune and
this might not have been as effective on
me or perhaps had I watched this unfold
in the anime I might not have enjoyed it
as much however as an arc that I can sit
down for an afternoon and consume assume
in a binge it's easily been the most
enjoyable sequence of the series for me
by a country mile too it's not even
close despite being right now situated a
decent ways into the climax I was still
unaware as to how this could possibly be
resolved and just as I had this feeling
kinjo ichigo's last Ally gets stabbed by
tsukushima oh my God tsukushima's speech
is legitimately chilling to listen to
talking about how he Ichigo is the only
one who has the memories he does now how
he is the one who's living the false
past all the while forcing us to watch
on as Orihime and Chad step in to defend
tsukushima it was one of the most
unsettling things to me which also
repackages their own desire oruhime and
Chad's desire to get better two get
stronger while Ichigo is out of action
turning that aspect of their characters
against Ichigo also reinforcing the
theme of this Arc which is to get back
into the action for Ichigo in the
previous Arc I was so jaded from fight
fighting seemingly for fighting's sake
whereas now with all of the
interpersonal relationships and
histories hanging in the balance I've
never had my attention held so perfectly
it's so good and then this happens
[Music]
[Music]
all of this time he was in cahoots with
sukushima having told him to stab him to
make it so that they were enemies to
avoid suspicion tsukushima's power and
genjo's convictions are precisely what
made this plan so convincing and
possible it's brilliantly unfolded it
feels so much less conventional and so
much darker I mentioned earlier that
ginjou is the MVP of this Arc and
honestly I stand by it in act one he
injects a fascinating sense of mystery
to the plot a sense of unease as well as
offering Ichigo the chance to regain his
powers in the second act he provides
Ichigo with a mentorship he needs in
this tough situation and as the
circumstances worsen and worsen he acts
almost like a big brother to him with
act 3 showcasing who he really is this
acts inverse of Ichigo someone who was
once on the same path Ichigo was on but
was left out in the cold couldn't form
trusting relationships with people which
ultimately leads to his device and I
think this next Point really speaks to
the character writing of this Arc but
each and every Act of this story simply
wouldn't work without him he facilitates
so much of what makes this Arc
interesting and possible and from the
very beginning he's deceitful but we let
it go due to how the ark manages our
attention and as the beat plot develops
we become more and more in need of
allies for Ichigo to latch onto as the
world comes crumbling down around him
thanks to tsukushima's mind manipulation
ability and once the perfect moment
reveals herself for ginjo to get his
mask off moment it is there for us to
relish it it's perfectly placed whether
or not I saw it coming is sort of
irrelevant I had my suspicions but
wasn't convinced but what I appreciated
was how it makes sense and how perfectly
timed the execution of this reveal was
the arc itself is wonderfully focused
and knows exactly what it wants to be
delivering this interesting contrast not
only between Ichigo and ginjou but
Ichigo and his former self I didn't
mention this at the beginning of the
video but the beginning of this Arc
shows a very clear contrast address
between the present now in this Arc and
the very first chapter of this series
but what's more is that I noticed in
this Arc more than any other I've read
it comes across as a contrast and
callback to the first Arc as a whole and
highlights how each and every Central
character has grown each go a character
that was once learning how to adopt
responsibility now yearnsford is
searching for it he wants to protect his
friends oruhime and Chad who are
characters that were left out in the
cold left entirely in the dark for so
much of that first Arc are instead the
ones now leaving Ichigo in the dark
trying to save him from trouble having
developed their own unique skill sets
for the sake of contributing to ichigo's
efforts and Urdu someone who once wanted
nothing more than to defeat humiliate
and remove Ichigo from the picture
specifically puts himself into
tremendous danger for the sake of
helping each go in his hour of beat and
following this otter low point with Urdu
shaking looking at ginjou with Orihime
and Chad compromised with Ichigo feeling
utterly alone and betrayed that's when
quite literally my favorite moment in
this series occurs
now to be clear this hasn't been a
series that's particularly tugged on my
heartstrings too much there's been
fleeting moments with orihime's goodbye
during the irankar arc that hit the spot
but truthfully I have not come close to
being too emotional but and I mean this
the feeling of Despair Kubo managed to
craft in this moment that high emotional
stake with the rewriting of history and
compromising everyone we love when
Ichigo turns around to discover Rukia
standing there as if like a guardian
angel someone finally who can offer
genuine help it reminded me of that
scene from end game fondly enough where
everyone comes through the portal at the
end to make the save on Captain America
seeing all of the captains we've
befriended come to the rescue offering
their power to Ichigo to win the day is
magnificently cathartic particularly
because we're doing it all for the
reasons ginjou and tsukushima are trying
to override because he go has genuinely
made an impact not only in this world
not only in his friend's world as
orihime's love for him is evident even
through her brainwashing but also in the
world of the Soul Society making this
very scene on top of all of that
narratively and emotionally earned in my
book well well well
how the turntables
no longer outnumbered each Captain takes
a battle that suits their own character
and due to us having spent a significant
amount of time with the other characters
we can actually enjoy those fights now
too not just because we know them mind
you but because this Arc hasn't shoved
fighting down my neck over and over and
because of that this section feels a
little more novel as a result
furthermore an example of something I
really appreciated in this story was how
Kubo didn't spend two or three chapters
on each individual fight before showing
a flashback to end it all Instead This
Arc dedicates a single chapter chapter
471 to the flashbacks of all of these
allies of ginjou together and the
delivery of this information in this way
serves these characters tremendously
well as this sort of shared group of
trauma that acts as The Binding which
unites them all it saves time and keeps
the pacing Snappy with each POV given a
unique background to help differentiate
them from each other within the chapter
itself yakiya's fight with tsukushima in
the end was again another affair that
forced an aspect of byakia outside of
his comfort zone creating a situation
where he couldn't rely on his ability to
diligently and dutifully prepare but one
where he had to embrace The Madness of
the moment enjoying something more akin
to what Kim patchy might enjoy funnily
enough forcing tsukushima to challenge
him head on something piakya points out
tsukushima isn't comfortable with so I
think this might be the first time I'm
reading a conclusion to a bleach Arc
where pretty much all of the antagonists
hit their Mark for me well okay except
for that one guy who likes time we
didn't really get to know him but that's
okay because Kubo recognizes that too
and had Kenpachi won't hit KO him in the
beginning which was just hilarious if
this was the Iraq Iraq it would have
taken another five chapters but I
digress with the full bring Arc itself
culminating on a single decision Ichigo
needs to make and it's a decision based
on trust ginjou tries to convince him of
the lies the soul Society have Laden him
with and paints a very dark picture that
contrasts what he thought his
relationship was however and I think
fittingly Ichigo irrespective of this
information reveal as he has suspected
it prior and that he still trusts them
because of course he would they came in
his hour of need they let him settle
this on his own terms and as we observed
ourselves ginjo and tsukushima aren't
exactly above deception either in the
end the likes of ginjou are defeated
tsukushima too oruhimi and Chada
restored back to normal and the smoke
screen that is the Deputy badge is
finally cleared and I can honestly say
that this more than any other Arc has
delivered for me the most brilliant
bleach experience to date
I think ultimately I really ended up
connecting with this Arc due to the
specific context I read it in that
context being my utter exhaustion and
exasperation following the onslaught of
fights that was the aranca rack unlike
the rankar arc and to a degree even the
soul Society Arc fullbring feels like a
fresh well executed smaller scoped but
necessary restart it contends with the
obvious consequences and followed of the
last dramatic conclusion and does so in
a really different way where the arankar
Arc was wall-to-wall combat tsukushima
is specifically non-confrontational
where Seoul Society offered conviction
for Ichigo to embrace fulbring took an
entirely different direction one that
made the entire Arc far less formulaic
and conventional compared to Soul
Society where substitute Shinigami
didn't dedicate all of its time to
telling one story fullbring manages to
utilize all of the secondary cast
retaining that same small town feel that
the first Arc enjoyed all the while
delivering a story that was entirely
unique and solid from beginning to end
it's not too long it's not too short it
has some of the best character writing
in the series all the while contending
with the storyline that's more in
keeping with a thriller than a battle
manga all of which only works due to our
knowledge of the existing characters it
possesses for me all the interpersonal
charm of the first Arc and all the
appeal of the Soul Society Arc without
any of the predictability which I
thought dated that Arc and weighed it
down a lot particularly in its second
half and unlike the rankar arc and the
Soul Society material I thought for the
first time in the series the secondary
Supporting Cast ended up contributing to
this Arc in such a compelling and
meaningful fashion for without the likes
of Urdu and Rukia coming to their
friends's aid to turn the tides and make
brilliant reveals or Chad and Orihime
helping Ichigo train and eventually
facilitate my favorite portion of the
story through their zombification this
story simply wouldn't have worked even
in the slightest fulbring is my antidote
to how the aranca arc made me feel and
my guess is that the anime much like how
I've noticed it did with other arcs it
may have done the same game with the
full brain that being either changed the
arc or inject so much filler that it
ruins the arc and for that reason I
cannot stress how wonderful and easy a
read it is in the manga at just 58
chapters in length it has something for
everyone I think it is for these reasons
and many more that I can safely say that
the fulbring Arc of bleach gets the
totally not marked thumbs up of approval
and so far it's the best archive red and
bleach comfortably it takes far more
risks and assumes a much less
conventional structure than I felt the
sole Society Arc did it delivers a much
more focused story than substitute
Shinigami and it is exactly as long as
it needs to be unlike the aranka rack to
me it's easily the best our Kubo has
penned and it's not even close
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
another place
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]